unflappable canine does not give a [ __ ]
I'm Kyle Kinane and these are some of my
favorite YouTube videos this first one
is simply called dog driving electric
car but it's so much more than that
the dogs fashion sense and concept of
timing is impeccable
[Music]
and I think my favorite part is how the
woman trying you a picture of the child
is not amused in the least the dog in
the car was sunglass next videos spook
dog falls down stairs at tuba sound they
just got right to the point
it's so hard
listen I mean the dogs probably alright
right
this one was introduced me today and
this next video is called husky puppy
falls down sir animals are never
supposed to fall like people like
animals don't have their like not
carrying a coffee in texting like
instinctually like they shouldn't do
this ah stupid dog I felt so much it
felt so much
look how confused it is at the bottom
let him go I don't watch it again
Oh lands on his feet though look at that
that's a good that's a good animal the
last video this one just called scared
Panda for the whole family just eaten
what's gonna that's easy that just makes
your day better this makes your life
better I mean this is the downfall of
the American white collar workforce but
mix your soul sing you know I'm Kyle
Kinane I hope you enjoyed these YouTube
videos and I hope they make your day a
little bit better a plus